Super Mario Odyssey isn't just Mario's biggest
adventure ever, or one of the best title of
2017: it's also a giant, sprawling love letter
to the portly plumber's video game history.
Odyssey might take Mario further than he's
ever been from the Mushroom Kingdom, but the
entire journey is absolutely drenched in callbacks
to his long and storied past.
Just watch out for spoilers: this list goes
into just a few of the big surprises waiting
for you.
A wonderful wardrobe
Super Mario Odyssey lets you buy a variety
of different outfits with your hard-earned
coins.
That's right: if you've gotten tired of Mario's
red and blue getup — or, if after 36 years,
you figure he's simply due for a change of
clothes — you can give Mario a makeover.
Some of the costumes are brand new to the
Mario series, but others have pretty obvious
origins.
Luigi, Wario, and Waluigi's outfits are all
available for purchase, and Mario's "Classic
Suit" makes his overalls red and his shirt
blue, just like in the very first Super Mario
Bros.
You'll also find some fairly obscure stuff
from Super Mario history: the "Chef Suit"
recalls Mario's days baking in Yoshi's Cookie.
The safari-ready "Explorer Suit" is a nod
to the Game Boy puzzler Mario's Picross, while
the "Poncho Costume" resembles Mario's outfit
in the Game Boy edition of Qix, as well as
one of his get-ups in his Japan-only anime
appearance.
The "Painter Outfit" references the Super
Nintendo title Mario Paint, the patriotic
"Golf Outfit" is from Open Tournament Golf,
while the "Aviator Outfit" sort of looks like
the clothes Mario wears in his first portable
outing, Super Mario Land, during that game's
shoot 'em up plane levels.
It goes even deeper, though, and unless you
know Mario's Japanese heritage, a few of these
are especially deep cuts.
Mario's "Mechanic Outfit" is borrowed from
1988's Famicom Grand Prix II: 3D Hot Rally,
a Japan-only racing game.
Mario's "Fashionable Outfit" isn't an old
reference, but it's still weirdly obscure.
In 2014, when Nintendo released its New 3DS,
it launched a Japanese advertising campaign
starring singer Kyary Pamyu Pamyu in which
Nintendo's classic characters get brand new
clothes.
Look familiar?
Celebrating Super Mario Maker
In 2015, Nintendo rolled out the last 2D Mario
game that anyone would ever need: Super Mario
Maker.
The new title flipped the script and let players
officially design and share their own Mario
levels for the first time.
And despite appearing on the underperforming
Wii U, Super Mario Maker sold over a million
copies and boasts over 7.2 million levels
for Mario fans to enjoy… or be impossibly
frustrated by.
By any measure, that's a hit — and one that
should keep fans and amateur game designers
busy for years to come.
Naturally, Nintendo put a few carefully-placed
Super Mario Maker Easter eggs in Odyssey,
like Mario's yellow and red "Builder Helmet
and Outfit," which can be purchased in New
Donk City's hat shop.
Super Mario Odyssey's other Mario Maker egg
is a little more subtle.
In some levels, you'll run across 8-bit pictures
of Mario and Princess Peach dressed in cat
outfits.
While the cat suit first appeared in the Wii
U's Super Mario 3D World, the sprites themselves
are from Super Mario Maker, appearing as one
of the costumes that Mario can wear.
In order to unlock the costumes in Super Mario
Maker, you'll need to clear a special event.
In Super Mario Odyssey, the sprites serve
a different purpose: hit them with Cappy,
Mario's new hat-like friend, and you'll get
a small health boost.
Mario 64, evolved
Odyssey owes more to Super Mario 64 than any
other Mario game, since both drop players
into wide open worlds filled with collectibles.
Platforming is still Mario's bread and butter,
but both of those games focus more on exploration
than mechanical challenges.
The games are connected by more than just
that, though.
Dorrie, the goggles-wearing Loch Ness Monster-like
creature who floats around the Lake Kingdom
made his debut in Super Mario 64, in which
players could ride him around in order to
discover new areas.
In the Wooded Kingdom, Mario needs to chase
down some terrified rabbits, not unlike a
series of similar rabbit-based chases that
take place in Princess Peach's basement in
Super Mario 64.
And while Mario stomps his way through various
kingdoms, he runs across paintings that transport
him to other worlds, which is a pretty clear
reference to Super Mario 64's hanging portraits,
which serve as gateways to that game's levels.
And if there was any doubt, Mario's goofy
low-def Mario 64 outfit is in here too.
All Kong, all the time
Most Mario fans know that Nintendo's mascot
first appeared in the company's 1981 hit arcade
game Donkey Kong, in which the mustachioed
construction worker had to rescue his girlfriend,
Pauline, from the big, dumb animal.
The game's New Donk City level is one giant
tribute to the 8-bit ape.
Pauline, once a damsel in distress, is now
New Donk City's beloved, singing mayor.
The city is also full of moving girders, and
intrepid explorers will find wooden barrels,
just like the kind Donkey Kong used to throw.
New Donk City's streets are also named after
characters from the Donkey Kong Country series,
including relatively obscure ones like Donkey
Kong's animal pals Rambi and Rattly.
Cranky Kong, who is canonically the original
Donkey Kong, gets his own avenue as well.
New Donk City license plates read "1981-ND,"
referring to Donkey Kong's release date.
And Super Mario Odyssey's jazzy title track,
"Jump Up, Super Star!", uses the original
Donkey Kong music as a backing melody.
And let's not forget about this.
When Mario first appeared in Donkey Kong,
he was known simply as "Jumpman".
You found a Power Moon!
Every time Mario finds a Power Moon, Super
Mario Odyssey's main collectible, Mario celebrates
with a victory pose, but they're not all the
same.
Sometimes, he puts up two fingers.
Sometimes, he triumphantly pumps his fist
in the air.
Occasionally, he keeps his hand open.
Unsurprisingly, there's a little bit of history
behind each one of those poses.
The split-fingered V-sign is what Mario does
after he finds a Star in Super Mario 64.
The fist pump hails from the two Super Mario
Galaxy games.
The open-handed pose comes from Super Mario
Sunshine.
It's a small touch, but it goes a long way
towards honoring Super Mario Odyssey's predecessors
— after all, Mario wouldn't be where he
is without 'em.
Toe-tapping tunes
While Super Mario Odyssey is full of visual
nods to the series' past, the game is also
full of auditory callbacks to past Super Mario
games.
For example, Mario runs across boom boxes
that pump out smooth jazzy covers of classic
Mario tracks.
If you use Cappy to possess the statues in
the Sand Kingdom, you'll notice that they
hum little snippets of past Super Mario soundtracks.
Return to the Mushroom Kingdom
Odyssey is a big game with lots to do.
And of course, as with most Mario games, beating
Bowser is just the beginning.
Once you defeat King Koopa and free Princess
Peach, the real challenge begins.
Not only is every world flooded with a new
set of Power Moons to hunt down, but Mario
can access a few new kingdoms — including
one that looks very, very familiar: the Mushroom
Kingdom.
Just like in Mario 64, Mario's home base is
full of things to do, with 104 more Power
Moons to discover, which is just under Mario
64's 120 stars.
You can access new challenges through paintings,
find Yoshi hiding on the castle grounds, and
even discover a few areas that look exactly
like their 64-bit counterparts.
The music is even the same as the original.
In addition, in a fun nostalgic throwback,
the Mushroom Kingdom's Power Moons look like
Mario 64's bright yellow stars.
Princess Peach may not be around, but it doesn't
really matter.
After all this time, it's just good to be
home.
"Wee-hoo!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!